my name is stephen air and i'm the
director of the fortune off video
archive for holocaust testimonies and
it's my pleasure to open the second
annual jeffrey hartman fellowship
symposium
i hope this day will prove to be an
enriching and productive one
i'd like to thank the fortune off family
in particular joshua nestor for being
here today
and all of the other donors blouse team
libyan ross families and dozens of
others large and small who help make the
archives work possible
the fortune of archives hartman
fellowship program now in its second
year was established in honor of jeffrey
hartman passed away on march 14 2016.
an eminent professor of comparative
literature at yale and the fortunate
video archives long time faculty advisor
jeffrey's vision and leadership helped
build the fortune archive into the
institution that it is today
the fellowship now in its second year is
a 12-month fellowship post-doctoral
fellowship for a single
new phd
and this year we expanded the program to
include a joint fellowship with the
vienna wiesenthal institute and i'd like
to thank eva kovacs and her husband
janos for coming all the way from vienna
to
to to be here today
to celebrate this initial
vwi fortune off joint fellowship
eva is the research program director at
the vienna viesental institute
the purpose of the hartman fellowship is
to provide scholars with an opportunity
to pursue deep research in the fortune
off collection to advance their own
scholarship as well as to produce an
annotated critical edition of a
testimony
now this critical edition is a testimony
transcript with annotations in an
introductory chapter
this um
these annotations in this chapter are
designed to illuminate the complexities
of the narrative and to include
additional information in context to
help readers
better understand or grasp the
complexity of a document like a
testimony in our from our collection
the essay the introductory essay
is designed to focus on the significance
of this testimony for holocaust history
in general
as well as the fellows scholarship in
particular
and our hope is that our fellows will
also after leaving here serve as
ambassadors to for the collection
as they continue to use it in their
research and teaching
at the next institution that they call
home
the critical additions
i hope unlock testimony and make them
accessible to a broader readership
and encourage both scholarly and
educational use of these resources at
various levels
we have two presentations today
and then we'll each of them will be
followed by q and we'll take a break
between them as well so people can get
refreshments
and the first
speaker will be sari siegel who is our
uh second jeffrey h hartman fellow
siri has an ma and a phd in history from
the university of southern california
and she received her ba from yale
university
the jeffrey h hartman post doctoral
fellowship brings her back
she earned her ba in 2006.
in addition to receiving numerous grants
and fellowships she has been a fellow in
residence at the center for holocaust
studies at the institute for
contemporary history
she's been a fellow at the vienna
wiesental institute and the u.s
holocaust memorial museum's jack joseph
and morton mandel center for advanced
holocaust studies
she has presented her research on jewish
prisoner physicians at many conferences
and workshops in the u.s and abroad
ceri will be presenting her work on the
testimony of edith f so please join me
in oh esther sorry esther f
so please join me in welcoming siri
thank you for the introduction stephen i
would also like to take this opportunity
to thank you for the fellowship
opportunity
and to thank the donors who have created
this position in the memory of the very
important scholar jeffrey hartman
uh it has been a pleasure to be a part
of the fortune off video archive
especially as it marks 40 years since
the taping of the first four testimonies
with this special series of events
thanks also go to kristy tomatrick
for her assistance with eclipse and to
debra bush for her assistance with just
about everything else
esther was born estera nissen house
on august 16 1908 in woods or lodge
poland
on october 9th 1991 when she was 83
years old esther sat for an interview
with yashael perry at the museum of
jewish heritage in new york
esther grew up in a traditional jewish
home
which kept kosher and observed shavut
but was not hasidic
she was fluent in yiddish
and polish and attended
a private jewish school with polish as
the language of instruction
unlike the majority of her peers
she was not affiliated
with youth groups or political parties
as a result of living living in a
predominantly jewish neighborhood and
attending a jewish school
she had limited encounters with
non-jewish polls and did not personally
experience anti-semitism
as a result of the numerous clauses that
severely limited jew's access to medical
education it within poland esther
traveled to france
she returned to lodge
with her medical degree in 1933.
interested in pediatrics she worked at a
children's hospital but then switched to
a position as a doctor for a workers
union
shortly before the german invasion of
poland
esther married a school principal whom
she last saw when he left for duty as an
officer in the polish army
he was captured shortly thereafter
and as a jewish pow eventually set to
the sent to the florida ghetto
from which he was later deported to
sophie boar
esther and other residents of lodge
renamed litzmanstadt by german officials
were forced to move into the city's
ghetto when it was first established in
february 1940.
she worked in one of the ghettos
hospitals and as a member of the
ghetto's emergency medical service
making house calls in response to
reported medical emergencies
she lived in the ghetto with her mother
and one of her brothers
all of whom were deported together to
auschwitz
when the ghetto was liquidated in august
1944
over those four and a half years
she and nearly all ghetto inhabitants
suffered from hunger
cold and fear of deportations
this image shows the doctors nurses and
emergency personnel of the hospital on
uh
going to try to do the polish
lagievnitzka street
it is unclear whether she is pictured
here
in august 1944 during the final
liquidation of the let's munch that
ghetto esther was deported along with
her brother and mother
to auschwitz-birkenau where she spent
five days in a section designated for
jews to be transferred to other camps
and utilized for slave labor
when a call went out for doctors she
identified herself and was subsequently
sent to work
as a doctor in guben a sub camp
connected to the gross rosen
concentration camp
located on the current border between
germany and poland this camp house young
women
assigned to work on radio equipment
for the german air force
after the camp was evacuated due to the
approach of the soviet army in early
february 1945
she traveled several days in an
uncovered truck and arrived at
bergen-belsen on february 15th
she received an assignment
from the head prisoner physician but
came down with typhus within two weeks
and was still recovering when the
british army liberated the camp on april
15
1945.
she moved a short distance to the
bergen-belsen displaced persons camp
which was established in nearby army
barracks
once she recovered she provided medical
attention to her fellow survivors
not desiring to return to her native
poland she decided to volunteer to be
among a group of dps to go to sweden for
further rehabilitation
they departed in july 1945 and she
continued her medical work in sweden
treating jewish dps
her work came to a halt however
once her fellow dps had recovered and
dispersed
she subsequently benefited from the
kindness of a prominent jewish doctor in
stockholm and worked in his forensic
medicine lab over this period she
entered into correspondence
with her husband's
first husband's best friend who was
living in new york
shortly after he arrived in sweden to
visit her
they were married
and in may 1947 she followed him to new
york where she eventually set up a
medical practice in pediatrics
she recorded her testimony for the
fortune off video archive on october 9th
1991 and then for the show off
foundation visual history archive on
january 30th 1995.
so why did i choose esther's testimony
given that my dissertation studied
jewish prisoner physicians in nazi camps
and then my next project will examine
holocaust survivors provision of medical
care
to fellow survivors in the early
post-war years esther's testimony seemed
like an ideal fit
after all she served as a doctor in
goobin and utilized her medical training
to help survivors in bergen-belsen and
then in dp camps in sweden
upon further exploration though
her testimony did not yield very much
insight into her medical work in these
venues
nevertheless i decided to work with hvt
2033 because as a result of my
dissertation research i was attuned to a
few threads that appear throughout
esther's testimony
furthermore the threads align with my
methodological approach the simultaneous
investigation of jewish doctors on micro
and macro levels
because jewish doctors medical training
provided them with knowledge and the
skill set required to treat the sick and
injured in ghettos and camps their
recruitment and or protection
offers at least to some extent
insight into the value accorded to the
lives of their prospective patients
in turn one can discern dynamics between
the pursuits of two different yet
overlapping initiatives
the exploitation of the jewish labor
force
and the extermination of european jewry
this line of reasoning is not without
exceptions of course
as jewish doctors were also mobilized
for the benefit of german officials own
health
however my dissertation research
revealed that this motivation was
generally secondary to the goal of
exploiting the jewish labor force
i can address this caveat as well as the
impact of insufficient medical supplies
in the q a
so how can esther's testimony offer
insight into the macro level dynamics
between these two major initiatives
the first three sites of her internment
are crucial the question of preserving
or liquidating blitz much.ghetto was one
of the key flash points between the
german officials most intent on
extermination
and those more invested in harnessing
jewish labor power for financial gain
and or for the benefit of the german war
effort
esther's references to official measures
taken to preserve the lives of ghetto
doctors and to reinforce the medical
staff more specifically the instructions
to perimeter guards not to shoot those
wearing particular medical insignia and
the facilitation of the recruitment of
additional doctors from the warsaw
ghetto in
mid-1941
communicate that doctors had value to
german officials as possible preservers
of the labor force
furthermore the ghettos
vertigo location is important as this
reich annexed region of western poland
was the manifestation or saw the
manifestation of this conflict in the
simultaneous proliferation of forced
labor camps for jews in 1941 42 and 43
and the operation of the nazis first
extermination site helmno beginning in
december 1941.
my dissertation research reveals that
each level of the civil government in
the vatigal including municipal
authorities in charge of the
lichmonts.ghetto
as well as officials in berlin and
german businesses
businessmen sorry
in public and private industry
either invest uh instigated or
facilitated the transfer of jewish
doctors from berlin to forced labor
camps for jews in the name of preserving
the labor force
when esther arrived in birkenau in
august 1944 and during the preceding
late spring and summer months
the camp's crematoria were working at
and beyond
capacity as transports arrived from the
lodge and from the lodge ghetto and from
hungary
at the same time however
new sections of the camp were
established to hold thousands of new
arrivals who were soon to be designated
for transport to hundreds of camps to
help the german war effort
so while her mother was immediately
dispatched to the gas chamber
esther was among those sent
to the so-called transit camps within
birkenau and she was transferred to
goobin only five days later
her transfer from bear canal
to serve as a doctor for jews working in
a factory manufacturing airplane radio
parts demonstrates a clear interest in
the preservation of jews labor capacity
the camp's location within the reich
proper draws further attention to the
importance of the jewish labor force as
the jews were brought back into the
territory
that was previously declared to be and
was meant to stay
unreine cleansed of jews
goobin was just one of around 100 gross
rosen subcamps dozens of which contained
prisoner populations comprised mostly or
entirely of jews
once she arrived
her experience communicates
that
at least to some extent
the german official in charge of the
camp had an interest in the medical
treatment of the inmates
is the volume okay
yeah
where does
would it be from the computer itself
let's do it from here
let's see
that didn't sound loud enough let's try
that again
i remember there thank you i was tired
so i caught like holding on something
cybergear or at the red one board the
inn
gave me the the holding and i wrote
aspirin
so there are the two things and
sometimes a minute later or whatever i
have a cotton
alcohol iodine and that's all maybe
another word i don't remember and she
came
and she says to me
that's all but you asked right now
evidently the female officer in charge
of the camp was prepared to provide more
supplies as she asked esther if the
doctor had listed all the supplies she
required
her experience echoes my findings
related to jewish prisoner physicians
within the industrial subcamps of
auschwitz
surviving doctors report that on a
variety of occasions
ss medical orderlies or doctors obtained
requested medical equipment or
medications and the importance of the
jewish doctors to the industrial program
is clear from their transfers from
birkenau to the subcamps and from one
subcamp to another
i would also like to draw attention to a
micro thread that runs throughout
esther's testimony the conduct of jewish
functionaries and the issue of judgment
although admittedly problematic and thus
a possible topic for discussion in the q
a
i'm offering the following tentative
definition of jewish functionaries
jews who held privileged positions
that and carried out tasks that in one
way or another and to varying extents
facilitated the achievement of the
german officials aims
as such
they existed in what holocaust survivor
and author primo levy calls
the gray zone a
quote poorly defined space where the two
camps of masters and servants both
diverge and converge end quote
recognizing the moral ambiguity of
functionary circumstances
levy cautioned against judgment of such
people writing quote this gray zone
possesses an incredibly complicated
internal structure and contains within
itself
enough to confuse our need to judge and
quote
esther's testimony offers an entry point
to discuss several examples of gray zone
figures who until relatively recently
have presented scholars with a taboo
topic
the jewish police in the ghetto or the
ordnance literally the order service
is one group of functionaries who master
discusses
interestingly as you will see jachael
perry the interviewer presses esther to
pronounce a judgment
which is actually a breach of fortune
off video archive's interviewer protocol
esther on the other hand
chooses to suspend judgment just as levy
suggests
there are some people
blaming the behavior of the jewish
police in the ghetto do you have some
opinion about it
i have my opinion but i don't know how
to explain it because some people i say
that i
prefer to die and not do these things
but others say that this is
self-preservation
so this is a question of i have to think
of it much more because i wasn't in this
position where i was to do i would call
it the dirty things i did but i could i
couldn't do more than i did
and i couldn't save everybody's life
but the other things
let's say they they they they collected
the people to the gathering places to be
deported now this was an order from
ronkowski
ordered from the german so if you were a
policeman you could have said i don't
want to do it
so you would have gone and you had a
family so now i don't want to go into
this it's too complicated and too hard
to accuse i don't know
evidently she recognizes
that moral calculus cannot account for
what amounts to a choiceless choice
which calls for the consideration of the
officer's family's welfare and the harm
that might come to them if the officers
were to disobey orders
she takes a similarly hesitant approach
to judgment in her discussion of one of
the most controversial figures in the
history of the holocaust mordecai
rumkowski
elder of the jews or june el testa of
the litzmunch.ghetto
i don't know
how right he was how wrong he was
because he obeyed the german and maybe
he would not obey would nobody remain in
the in the ghetto but if you want to be
honorable instead like to say die on
your feet and not to live on your knees
you we shouldn't have had this but this
is good for individuals but not to
so the history will judge him how right
or how wrong people but being in the
ghetto he abused his power too he was an
older man and he once was something in
the hospital i didn't work in this
because i lived on one side of the
bridge and the doctors who lived on the
other side worked in the other hospital
it was something with the nurses he was
going into different
heats one there's another so so the
doctor who was on cheap
objected so he always hit him too
so these were inner things
painful to mention too but history will
judge this i'm not going to say what was
right and what was wrong but there's a
lot of
abuses and a lot of things that
shouldn't have happened but as you say
you by it is self-preservation
i am not going into psychology right now
i don't think so we have and i don't
want to even
be the judge of all this
she believes judgment should be deferred
until history renders a verdict yet by
1991 when she recorded these words
nearly 50 years after the ghetto's
liquidation
when would such a verdict be pronounced
and who would be in a position to do so
why the need for judgment in the first
place
again perry asks esther to pass judgment
on a group of functionaries but this
time when it comes to the ghetto doctors
there is no hesitation
how would you looking backward what
you experienced that as a doctor with
your colleagues in the circumstances you
had there in the ghetto
how would you judge their action now
of the doctors
the doctors how did they behave and how
did they act in these circumstances i
would say
very decent
and everybody tries you see it's hard to
say to try and to do because there are
two difficult things
we have paralyzed hands but we did but
nobody abused anything but as far as i
know and i'm sure there wasn't to abuse
in any way patience or neglect patient
or to collaborate with german not at all
not at all none of them
perhaps she was not aware or no longer
recalls but there were ghetto doctors
who under coercion assisted nazis in
mass murder
nazi officials required jewish doctors
to perform medical examinations on
people on deportation lists to determine
whether they were appropriate candidates
for the fate that awaited them at a
particular transports assigned
destination
either a forced labor camp
or helno
as a result
ghetto doctors like arnold mostovich
could only protect a few individuals by
finding them undesirable candidates for
the transport
in other words
he and the other doctors who were
coerced into carrying out this process
had to decide who would be exempt from
the transports
and in doing so they had to determine
who would live and who would die
while there was significant coercive
pressure on wastovich
it was largely indirect originating with
ghetto uh sorry with german officials
and conveyed to him via the so-called
jewish self-government in the ghetto
circumstances were different
in camps however where the ss performed
direct supervision and thus exerted the
coercive force directly
although esther's testimony does not
afford much insight into that dynamic
she does discuss an act of resistance
once in a while became a german
official to check how i was there and i
kept a little bit that double
bookkeeping for him i showed the
temperature and everything a little bit
on the normal side and the real i didn't
show the book the majority had to be i
don't know he should know it he didn't
examine he only took it so i tried to
say
through my work on jewish prisoner
physicians i have devised a framework to
add to to aid conceptualization
and discussion of these functionaries
and potentially other functionaries
behavior the coercion resistance
spectrum
unlike gravy levy's gray zone
it sets acts of resistance firmly in the
discussion
and it emphasizes the dynamic of
coercion as opposed to the loaded and
largely inappropriate term collaboration
the word spectrum is not indicative of
an array between polar opposites
according to which a particular act
could be situated and categorized
instead it serves to draw attention to
the wide range of possible courses of
action
the thrust of the model is what i call
historicizing the gray zone and drawing
attention to the shifts in behavior and
the changes in environmental factors
that influence a prisoner physician's
room for maneuver
so in esther's case the combination of
the infrequency of the ss doctor's
visits and his lack of interest in
personally examining her patients
enabled her to keep two sets of medical
records and thereby potentially save the
lives of her patients with tuberculosis
a diagnosis that could have been a death
sentence
given that esther's testimony offers
limited insight into her work as a
prisoner physician at goobin and because
typhus largely kept her for medical work
at bergen-belsen i am not able to
approach my introductory essay as i had
hoped when i first embarked on this
critical edition project
i simply do not have enough content to
mobilize the coercion resistance
spectrum framework in my discussion of
her testimony
however
as i have demonstrated here
i am able to bring my dissertation
research to bear in another way
the insights i have gained through my
macro level work on prisoner physicians
enable me to read between the lines of
esther's testimony
and address how her presence as a doctor
as well as the events and places she
describes
sheds light on the interaction between
two central german initiatives during
the holocaust exploitation and
extermination
in other words i am able to address the
testimony's relationship to the macro
scale narrative of the holocaust
as such i can point out how the history
behind the testimony challenges the
outdated intel
sorry intentionalist narrative that
based on the following
perry evidently espouses he asks
quote looking backward again about the
starvation and the illness and sickness
and the conditions in the ghetto do you
think that all this was planned ahead by
the germans the situation in the ghetto
before the liquidation
and quote shortly thereafter he adds
quote
i read somewhere that they did
they planned it purposely this way end
quote
consequently
as a historiography of the functionalist
intentionalist debate has given way to
more nuanced studies
my critical edition essay will among
other things
introduce jewish doctors as a lens
through which to view macro level
developments
thanks for your attention i look forward
to comments and questions
[Applause]
questions for siri
maybe i missed something but you talked
about dr nostovic
could you elaborate yeah because it's
like i don't know
yeah so he
uh
as a doctor in the lodge ghetto uh wrote
a memoir so he sheds the the most light
on what went on there
from the the medical team okay so i can
uh let you know about that later if you
want no i do know about it oh
joshua what for you were the
most surprising revelations from your
studies what were the things that you
thought you might find and turned out
different
uh
generally when i when i read the
the summary of her
holocaust trajectory
and what she did
it seemed like i had hit on something
golden
this is exactly what i do and what i'm
going to do in that she was a prisoner
physician
and she also worked as a doctor in a
ghetto
and then she worked as a doctor in dp
camps
something that i'm gonna hopefully do
with my next project
so
uh
that that was just
right there for me
and then i realized
there is a little meat there but not
very much
so how how can i bring something else
to the table here so i
i can't really engage in as i said the
coercion resistance spectrum
framework
because there's not enough there it
would it would be too much of a reach
however
it occurred to me
wait i have
dealt with some of these issues
in terms of the the macro scale she does
provide insights
that i can point out
odds are people aren't necessarily going
to pick up on oh she she mentions that
the doctors were supposed to
wear a certain cap so they wouldn't get
shot at
and uh
and urankowski brought back some doctors
for or brought in some doctors from
warsaw
uh
to me that signals wait a sec
they want to protect doctors the
officials want to protect doctors and
they facilitated
the transfer of doctors from the warsaw
ghetto to the woods get it why
so that
these are small clues that that draw my
attention towards a larger fact of
course
by pointing this out i'm in no way
negating the horrific circumstances
that the jews lived
in the woods ghetto
but the fact that this that that these
tiny details come out of the of the
testimony it says something
and
generally when we're talking about the
the horrible conditions
it wasn't entirely
brought on by
bebof the the head of
the
um
the ghetto administration
there were plenty of people on other
levels
working at cross purposes and for their
own enrichment
that took food that took medication that
was meant for the jews again
horrible circumstances
odds are the
the nazis were fined with
mass death
but there was something there
that they
wanted to do
and i see that as
preserving doctors lives
and in in some cases letting medication
enter the ghetto
and providing them with minimal supplies
to keep the workers alive that's how
rumkowski kept the ghetto going
it was important to the war effort
so
that
that gives me some
something to put in the micro i mean in
the macro okay
did you look at any other doctor
or prisoner
physicians
why again esther
if others had more
meat
was
first the first part of the question did
you look at other physicians and did you
find anything else that would be useful
for your research
uh
so there are
testimonies of prisoner physicians
however they weren't in the regions that
i specialized in so i wasn't able to
bring to bear the knowledge of the
vartagal for example which is the
location of the woods ghetto
i had a a case study
on the force on doctors in the forced
labor camps for jews in the vartigo so i
have some grasp of the mechanisms going
on there what are the the dynamics
and
and i also have a
case study on
the on doctors in
the industrial subcamps of birkenau
which is parallel to guben
so
cuban's relationship to
gross rosen so
these
fit better although
although the meat wasn't there i felt
like i could bring more
of what i specialized in to some extent
to
to bear on
on the the topic whereas other
doctors were in the general government
uh an area that i would love to study
more but i haven't gotten there yet so
that that's why i chose esther and uh
and still
even though i can't bring what i thought
i could to it
i i still think and of course
you can weigh in
whether
what i'm bringing is
is substantial enough in terms of the
idea of
macro level
insights
and
uh and micro level
activities and judgments
of course the biggest to me because
irony here is
that by preserving life she's helping
the german war effort which in the end
would have brought the destruction of
everybody and i don't know if that's
discussed a lot
at least in my reading
of the holocaust
so
and of course
the biggest problem was starvation i
mean people were dying of starvation
which she could not uh
impact i guess unless that was
something that she brought up to the
people in the camp that if you don't
feed people
you know of course then they have this
endless line of people not endless but
so
i mean i don't know how much this is
discussed this
i mean it's discussed in terms of
romkowski in terms of his
efforts which preserves himself but this
is also going on at this other level
you're absolutely right
in fact esther does mention
that
her efforts
and
as as a doctor for workers and what the
workers were doing themselves could be
viewed as collaboration she actually
mobilizes that word which was
so fascinating to me
because there was an awareness that the
effort they put in
on the doctor's part to save the lives
of the workers who
were helping the german war effort which
as you pointed out
would keep the war going would pose
greater problems to a
larger
jewish population
that was an ethical issue so
uh
in the
growing scholarship on on resistance
there's
discussion of
people sabotaging in in these workplaces
so there was awareness and and
some of the workers tried to
go in and
sabotage to
hurt the the war effort uh as for the
prisoner physicians
they're
of the ones that i studied the the
memoirs i read the
testimonies they gave there was some
awareness that what they were doing was
prolonged potentially contributing to
prolonging the war
but at the same time
they were also
adhering to the hippocratic oath
their job
as doctors was
to take care of patients
so
just doing what they're supposed to do
had a bigger impact but
the the important thing is is trying to
help the person in front of them to the
greatest extent possible
um
the fact that she was a female doctor
and a pediatrician
that was different from other
testimonies that you've looked at or
does it
put her along with other female doctors
i know it's more a deeper research topic
but just wondering what you thought of
that
um
it's something that crept into my mind
when i was making the decision
the the other testimonies of
doctors were men so
uh
generally i'm just a huge fan of women
in medicine
um on an underrepresented
uh
group and so the fact that i could draw
attention to a woman in medicine and
a woman in medicine at that time in the
30s in poland she was overcoming not
just the
uh
the hurdle of being jewish with the
numerous closes but being a woman
studying the sciences and pursuing
a course in in medicine so she herself
addresses this double problem which i i
find fascinating
larry
female doctors in auschwitz vehicle now
have written that they were often asked
to accompany ss men
during selections of the barracks
and they have written that
they would choose
the prisoners whom they thought were on
the verge of death anyway they knew that
the people they were choosing were going
to the gasoline
do we know if
esther knew that people being
transported out of the lord's ghetto
were being sent to their death rather
than to labor camps which is the story
the germans were telling
uh
okay just based on the last thing the
story the germans were telling in some
cases they were actually sent to labor
camps um
as far as i can tell from this testimony
and i have to spend more time with the
showa foundation testimony as far as i
can tell she was not on one of the the
commissions
uh for doctors who
look who performed examinations on
people
on transport lists
so
that's an important fact
as for her level of awareness of what
was happening to the people who left the
ghetto
i'm not sure when
she came to the awareness that
these people just don't come back
uh
that that's unclear
um but she does talk about
the
horrific
uh kinder action the
um
the the nazis going in and taking out
all the
the children uh in
um september 42.
and and the elderly and clearing out the
hospitals and the violence
so there's a sense that there's a major
danger
but
i i don't know for sure
but uh in my dissertation i
address
those doctors and and what's fascinating
is that some of them didn't want to get
involved in the process in the in the
first place
and they were presented with
if i may a choiceless choice
and
they they could
not
do anything
which would mean the ss doctor would
pick at random
who was going to the gas chamber because
x number of people had to come out of
the hospital
and that meant maybe some people who had
a chance of surviving one you know a
person who was one day away from release
because
she
was
getting better
maybe that person would be sent to the
gas chamber whereas other people who are
about to die would be left there so that
was one option the other option
was
actually participating
in these selections
knowing who was going to die
of quote-unquote natural causes
very close to death
and
they had no no chance of recovery so
kicking that
that was actually acting
so
i i
i'd like to put your term out there you
you have to let me know whether
i'm conceiving of it correctly
okay
very relieved there
okay
we can talk after if they're criticisms
okay
so i'm interested in
how you conceptualize resistance
because in these in this
concentrationary universe
all these ethical terms
are up for grabs
and so i'm interested in
what your working definition of if you
have one of resistance
um
well
i believe the term has been deployed a
bit too much
when it comes to the extreme of
breathing was resistance because they
were staying alive and the nazis wanted
to kill them all
so i back away from that
extreme
i also back away from the extreme that
the definition of resistance has to be
armed resistance so
i i'm in from the extremes
and
uh so that much i can say i've carved
out what's still a really large area
um
i
i
um
i eliminate
the acts
of resistance that are perceived by
others but
the person engaged in whatever act did
not uh
think of his or her action as resistance
i look at it as as something
that uh you know someone
took agency
to resist there had to be an awareness
of it so
self-awareness yes thank you
self-awareness uh so that's one way and
generally for me it's
so it's a self-aware
act that in some way to some extent
would
thwart
nazi aims
so that that's my working definition
so you talked thanks little bit about uh
during your election now you talked a
little bit about
the interview and process itself and the
uh interactions between the interviewer
and uh and the witness and i kind of
wanted to hear what you had to say about
that in relation to the
spectrum of
the coercion and resistance that you're
talking about
because it seems as if
that
had
had very um large connection
like not only in fact that the
interviewer seemed to breach
protocols and
ask for for this kind of judgment but
also the
perhaps resistance that
the witness
kind of portrayed within the interview
itself
um
so
one thing that i had as i was looking
through
the the testimony i believe they were
joanne's notes
and
in brackets in many places along the way
the comments were like
he's he's not supposed to ask that
how is how is the witness supposed to
know the answer to this big
historiographical question
and
i i could feel the frustration i'm
assuming it's it's you
yeah
just like what is this guy doing
um he is
actively inserting himself he is asking
these big questions that someone
in in her own life and her that's what
she's the expert on that's what she's
there to talk about
but he was like oh yeah i read
that uh that
you know the germans had this in mind
from the beginning well good for you but
uh
this is about esther
so
uh so it was it was frustrating for me
and i felt for joanne through those
notes that she probably wanted to reach
her hand through the screen
and i don't know what um
uh
he
he
as far as i can recall he didn't engage
once she put that double bookkeeping out
there
that was a point he he he didn't latch
on to that
um
i i would need to watch the whole thing
in its entirety
again but
i i'm not sure whether he asked oh was
there
resistance
he
based on what i've pulled he seemed to
be more fixated on
the
the idea of the collaboration
but that's a really interesting point
and another thing to say in terms of of
my construction of this
spectrum model
um
based on what he's showing i think he's
nowhere near that conceptual point of
nuance he just
simply is is not there
so
uh
so it i i can't really bring it into his
universe because he's he's just not on
it
one more question okay
were the prisoner doctors
i sympathize for the decisions that they
had to make
at times
and i was wondering if they were
sufficiently valuable enough to the
germans that they were treated in a way
to keep them alive
that's a great question
it depends on the camp it depends where
when
generally they had extra food
in some cases that was prescribed
extra rations to keep them alive to do
their doctorly thing
in other cases
it was
they ate the food
for
prisoners who couldn't eat it
and they also shared it with with people
in the barracks
so
um so generally
they were pretty well fed the fact just
the fact that they worked inside as
opposed to on an outside labor commando
that kept them alive longer
to to do what they were doing
um
and
because they didn't work under
the cruel watchful eye
of a horrible capo they were generally
under
under the watch of a head doctor
whether it's a jewish doctor or not
the the business within these
they were called hospitals or clinics or
uh
yeah either
yes that's the term that comes up i'm
trying and heffling's krankenbauer
krankenbauer cabe so yeah
so i'm just trying to translate
the the different meanings um
so
they they weren't exposed to the same
kind of violence
so how
conscious of a decision
that was on on the part of
camp leadership
i i can't tell you
but it was a fact that they were spared
some of the disastrous
horrific circumstances that the average
prisoner
had to confront
i just want to address this point i
think the most important thing you said
was at the beginning
and where because plenty of doctors
were selected as soon as they arrived
for death even though they were known to
be physicians
and it just depended where and when
maybe i'm the supply of you too no it
was
just what was happening at that moment
in time
you know it it's so random it's
it's not systematic we always think that
the nazi regime was
rational systematic it was not it was
actually quite chaotic
not in the vartagal when it came to
doctors
right so
so yes i
see testimonies
of people whose parents were physicians
yes and the person selecting them knew
they were physicians but so you're two
you're too old you've lived there's one
yeah
there's one testimony i think her name
is gertrude mossberg um
she said oh about my father's a
physician
oh how old is he and she states the age
oh he's lived long enough it's okay
so you're you're right they
but at the same time
again depending on when if we're talking
if we're talking um beer canal
there was a stage when the
ss physicians performing selections
were told to spare the lives of jewish
doctors and this was in 44 when labor
was crucial
and those people were
transferred from
birkenau to monovitz to the other
subcamps so there was a concerted effort
and you could
see in the documentation
this person this doctor is transferred
on the order of the head
physician the head ss physician
so
so you're right it changed but there
were
attempts at
systematizing this selection the
positive selection of of doctors
okay
well thank you siri
[Applause]
[Music]
you